[Music]
I'll be fine
bug head is relationshipgoals on and off
screen but Lily Reinhardt has always
played coy about her real-life romance
with co-star Cole Sprouse any other
kisses Lily
[Music]
I like the couples on the show in a new
interview with Harper's Bazaar the
Riverdale star explains why talking
about her boyfriend is off-limits
telling the mad quote I'm not okay
talking about my relationship I'm not
going to tell you my love story that's
just not appropriate right now
unacceptable
well everything while Lily remains
tight-lipped about her love life she did
not keep quiet when fans speculated she
was expecting her first child with Cole
after an unflattering pic surfaced the
actress opened up to et about her
reaction to the pregnancy rumors it was
bugging me and in at first it was really
upsetting and you know you don't want to
21 I'm not pregnant you don't want to
blue I don't people think I'm pregnant
if I'm not pregnant so you know it did
take a hit to my self-esteem for a
second and then I kind of picked myself
back up and said
I'm not gonna let this ruin my day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]